foreign
let's go to the buff Buffalo New York Dr
Jerry what's up Jerry
hi Dr D how are you so much for taking
my call I'm I'm operating breathing so
it's a good day that's a good one
excellent what's happening what's up
oh I am having issues with my adult
daughter okay um
the last few years it's it's gotten way
worse we have you know constant blow-ups
and then we'll
we'll sit down and talk and things will
be better for a while
um I find myself walking on eggshells
around her but you know we kind of get
through it um is she is she an addict
does she use
no no not at all um she's very very
angry
um
um
my ex-husband when she was growing up
they had a trip where they were either
really getting along or they really
weren't
and he uh they were in an argument one
day and he pushed her
and she feels I didn't do anything about
it she's right I I should have left
right then and there yeah
um
oh but well I the last time that we had
this
um a blow up the blow-ups are over other
things but it always goes back to you
know deep down she's angry with me and I
get it
and I've apologized and I've offered to
you know I've asked her to please go to
counseling because I you know I use your
analogy of you're drinking poison
waiting for him to die it's just it's
crazy
so
um it's gotten even worse in the last
year and a half she left her husband
um she was got really angry because we
were all friends with him
so our point was well he's the father of
our grandchild so
so we gave in and
none of us are friends with him anymore
you know we we keep our distance uh
um but every time we have these blow ups
she won't let me see the grandchildren
why do you keep having blobs with her
um it's always always
something like the the slightest thing
will just set her off
I know but you know those things
why do you engage her yes why I I I
don't think I do I I like I told you I
tiptoe around her and I hate that
feeling but I I know what sets her off
the problem is
she has a very very good relationship
with my my husband
um
is she you know doesn't have a good
relationship with her dad she confides
in my husband and I love seeing her have
somebody like that
um but I think he him and I have been
talking the last couple weeks because it
I'm really at a Crossroads I don't know
what to do
I think he fuels the fire but he doesn't
understand you know he says little
things to her that I would never you
know I can fight in him and then
he I don't think he means to
you know weak things to her
but there are things that I know are
gonna set her off um an example is she
asked me to go to dinner with her a
couple months ago which we used to do
everything together when she was little
I mean we baked we exercised we shopped
we did everything together I was there
for both of the kids I was in the room
when both of them were born
um but like a couple months ago she had
asked me to go out to dinner and like I
said we've been straying the last you
know two or three years
so I said to my husband I'm like I'm
like that's kind of uh I'm like it's
nice yes I want to go to dinner I'm like
and uh you know I was hoping for good
things well he
said something to her that you know he's
like I don't know why you YouTube
questioning each other so then she got
mad at me because I questioned why she
wanted to go out to dinner
so your husband is not at fault here
okay yeah
foreign
I want you just to settle in for a
second okay
yep
whether she knows it or not there's
still a little girl in there wondering
what was it about that guy that was more
important than me when we when I was
little
right why did my mom pick him over me
and
the wave and the way you said that that
when things were good they were so good
and they were bad they were really bad
when that happens with a kid there is no
real good
and that usually is somebody trying to
balance out their inaction
or excuse some of their inaction okay
you said it you're right you should have
left
you should have left before he pushed
her but here we are I also know
um not purse not first hand but I've sat
with enough people to know
the fear of being a single parent the
economic insecurity the the I understand
the plight women have to go through
to eat something I get it it's a mess
and it's easy to look back 25 or 30
years later and go I should have I
should have I should have and then in
the middle of it you start to think well
the next stop is the back of our station
wagon and I don't have a right and so
here we are
now
and the we used to do everything
together cool that is in the past and
the more you go back to there you are
choosing to drink poison
we got to be right here right now
you're walking on eggshells around her
is a anxiety response she cannot anchor
into you because you're not fully
present you keep secrets from her you
don't tell her the truth you don't tell
her everything
and when you don't she knows it she
knows she's being angry and unreasonable
and annoying and frustrated she knows
that
and she also knows Mom's not telling me
the truth
and mom's still trying to treat me like
I'm 10.
think about it she laughed
let me see it this way you might think
you're a safe place her behavior is
telling us all that you she does not see
that right okay so the goal is less how
do I get her to do what I want
the goal is how do I become a safe place
for her not a doormat
how do I become a safe place and and
that's what I'm looking for I I don't
have the tools to you know our our last
blow up
um I I told I you know she's very much
a yeller and I and I told her I you know
I'm I understand if you're upset with me
but please sit down and talk to me so we
did we sat and talked for three hours
and I and I thought we really got to a
much better place
um and I told her I can't I can't go
back and fix anything I've done I was a
young mother I had no idea what I was
doing that's right um I said I can't fix
any of that but what I can do is do
better going forward and here's the hard
part here's the hard part
yeah what you just said is
is gold
it's such a gift
and that's the extent of what you can do
and if she chooses to not plug back in
that's a choice she's making
right and it hurts like bloody hell
it does
I made a million mistakes when my kids
are growing up
um I have a very good relationship with
my son
um don't don't compare them no no I I
don't I don't want to do that I want to
fix for her and I I want to be there for
her I you know I I don't want to see her
hurting like this that's right I mean
she's definitely hurting and I don't I
hate seeing that and the other thing is
is every time she you know she knows the
one thing that she can get to me with is
these grandchildren and they're seeing
this and and I they're looking I can't
get through to her that they're seeing
how to treat a mother you know when they
get older
I I don't want to see them doing this to
you and you're trade showing them how to
be I know what to be to women and and
their future why that's true but flip
around the other side
I've been really frustrated with my
parents before real frustrated actually
I've never once a thought I need to keep
my kids from them
exactly and I said hold on hold on hold
on
it could be that she's evil she's just
evil and she's weaponizing her children
to get back at her mother for something
her mother did 25 years ago I don't
think that's the case I think that she
doesn't think you're safe
okay
I can agree with that and so
let's don't demonize her even if she's
doing stupid things
okay let's go back to the basics the OG
Basics what can you control your
thoughts and your actions that's it
that's it okay you cannot control this
young girl you've been trying her whole
life and you can't and you also can't go
back and undo what happened it happened
you gotta own it and you have which is
impressive but what you haven't done is
started trying to write something new
you keep going trying to go back and
edit it I know right you got it happened
it is and these grandkids are not your
Redemption story they're not your
do-over
they're new people they're new people
and so
I would sit down and really map out what
are my boundaries
and a gift for her that's not going to
feel like a gift at first
is saying hey I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna do blow ups with you anymore I
love you too much and I'm not interested
in going to war with you I'm interested
in loving you and being a safe place
you've never been a safe place I I know
I know
um but I'm working on it now and so when
you raise your voice that's you choosing
to end a conversation with me
okay in these three-hour marathons feel
so cathartic
but they're not accomplishing anything
okay are they
I I thought you feel better you feel
better yeah but when you're talking to
somebody in fight or flight you're not
they're calming down but there's no
resolution
okay and a lot of times the resolution
after one of those three hour marathon
talks is people are exhausted they're
tired they're dropping their shoulders
for the first time in a long time
because their bodies aren't at War
and then the neck you got to do those
things you you got to teach your body
over time there's not this one big
conversation that's going to accomplish
everything
but again you're trying to find the
right thing to say trying to find the
right thing to do trying to find
shh
your daughter feels that you're trying
to Puppet Master still after all these
years
and it's going to be you saying I'm just
not going to do that anymore I love you
too much I love those kids too much I
love you
I'm not gonna fight you
yeah I I can feel the anxiety when when
we're together and it never used to be
like that but but you I want you to take
full ownership I have found myself
getting anxious around my own daughter
and yes you should be the one safe place
for me besides my husband
and that's on me I'm gonna stop being
anxious around you but that also means
you're going to stop you I I'm not I'm
just going to choose to opt out when you
yell
because I'm worth more than that
and I'm going to choose to opt out when
you swear at me and if you choose to
take the Korean kids away I'm I'm gonna
choose to have my heart broken but I'm
not gonna fight you
I'm just not gonna fight you anymore
well and that's where I'm at like I'm
I'm not okay not seeing these these
grandkids for but you don't get a vote
Jerry
you know you know what I mean
yeah you don't get a vote
and my husband you know
you know before I reached back out to
her I feel like I need to work on me a
little bit like there's this is just a
cycle that I just I want to get out of
so maybe you you can do both it's not
either or
okay maybe you reach out and say
um even take a disproportionate amount
of the blame
okay but
I would have a conversation with her
that's really somewhat jerry-centric
very you centered
okay
I'm sorry how I've acted
and I'm your mom and I feel anxious
around you and I'm not doing that
anymore because I love you too much
this isn't War this is you're my
daughter
and I'm committed to my own growth I
can't change you I can't change your
decisions to take the kids away but I
can become a safer place
and okay by becoming a safer place I'm
going to have boundaries and if you
don't like the boundaries that's fine
I'm just not gonna fight you anymore and
I'm going to see my own counselor I'm
going to go work on me and I'd love for
you to come with me
and if you don't want to great yeah cool
but here's the thing she will naturally
be drawn to you like a tractor beam
the more stable and safe and firm you
feel
okay okay the more you're trying to have
a new plan and you read a new book and
watched and read a new Instagram post
and you're gonna fix her on that dude
she can feel it a hundred miles away
okay
and think about how much more peaceful
of a life you're gonna have
yeah
yeah and that's the thing I'm at a
Crossroads like I can't I can't feel
like this anymore set the swords down
set them just set them down
yeah no more fighting
I'm not gonna do blow-ups I'm not gonna
do War I'm not gonna do any of it I will
be gut wrenched if you take those if you
don't let me see the kids
but I also know they're your kids and I
can't fight you over
if they're ever being abused or unsafe
I'm gonna call every Authority I have
but you don't have to bring that up in
this conversation
right right and and no I mean it's it's
you know not a situation like that I
just
it's exhausting and I know it's
exhausting for her too and I want to be
able to help her like she you know she
works full-time and she does very well
she's you know but I want to be able to
help her you know if she needs I know
but she's not asking for your help
I know you have to reconcile that
the more you try to insert yourself into
her life
the more it's just going to be an
electrified situation
the more you become a safe place
the more you're going to end up seeing
those grandkids the more you're going to
end up seeing her and the more you're
all gonna be able to heal your
relationship
okay
does that make sense
it does I heard over the weekend I don't
know how much truth this is
um I was at an event in Phoenix and
somebody was telling me that
um
I think it was I think it's where I
think anyway it doesn't matter where I
heard it
um that Memorial Gorbachev and uh Ronald
Reagan
when they were figuring out communism
and capitalism and and they had they
were meeting and they were in a heated
heated argument about how stupid your
capitalism is and how damaging your your
um communism is a back and forth back
and forth in the room they said it was
getting hotter and hotter and hotter
like two egotistical world leaders
getting ready to get pushed over the
edge right and out of nowhere they said
Reagan disengages and walks away which
is a very strange move
okay he said he walked away and was gone
for a minute and then Circle back and
walked back in with his with a huge
smile on his face
in an outstretched hand like to shake
his hand
and he said something like hey Mikey my
name's Ronnie how are you doing
and they boast it was so they both
started laughing
and he reset it I'm not fighting you we
gotta be friends yeah
that's the only way this thing works
moving forward right or everybody ends
up in Ash and again I don't know how
much of that story is folklore I don't
know how much that story is real but the
sentiment behind it is true there comes
a moment when we get so angry and so
frustrated we fall over the edge and
before you fall over the edge you're the
adult you're the mom you're the parent
she's an adult too but you're the parent
I'm I'm stepping away I'm gonna Circle
back I'm going to take my time I'm gonna
take a breath I'm gonna come back in
with a smile and say
yeah this is different from this point
forward and you are gonna sleep better
yeah because you're tired of War too
right yeah yeah and that's what I meant
by I I need to work on me I I mean
obviously I'm you know pushing buttons
and I'm you're right I try to edit the
past and I I'm the one that told her I
can't do that I can't fix any of it but
I can do better going forward and I
still go to the past but and you're
going forward is a trying to erase the
past and rewrite it can't do that you're
going forward is you trying to acutely
insert yourself into her life which she
has not asked for you trying to give her
parenting advice and mothering advice
and help I'll help you I'll help you I'm
not asking for your help I just want my
mom
yeah
and you have a picture in your head of
what Grandma's supposed to be doing with
their kids and that's not the picture
that your daughter has and if you want
to be in a relationship with her and
your grandkids her picture is the one
that's going to matter
it's like when somebody says hey my kids
decided they're not coming up for
Christmas I'm so ticked off I'm pissed
I'm gonna call them why
because they're not gonna come for
Christmas either
yeah and that's it all of that is an
antidote to sitting down to not wanting
to sit down and go I'm really sad that
my kids aren't going to be here for
Thanksgiving my Thanksgiving is going to
look different now I'm going to have to
invite people over and it's going to be
kind of boring or weird right I've got
to deal with the Reality Part
and so I'd love to see you create an
anti-war document
this is full of your boundaries
here's what I'm not going to tolerate
you can't cuss at me you can't just show
up here in the middle of the night if I
find out you're using or the kids aren't
safe I'm gonna call you on it here's my
boundaries
and then I think your husband's right
reach out and but the reaching out is a
declaration of peace and it's a
declaration of I'm changing and I love
you and I
here's the deal that's all you got left
and everybody listening to this if you
find yourself
like like Jerry you're what you're
talking about is so common it's common
in marriages it's common between parents
and young kids it just turns into this
cycle of I will defeat you I will solve
you I will I've got bigger muscles than
you I I've got more power than you
and it just ends in ashes
and at some point someone's got to back
out and just say hey control alt delete
reset I'm not going to war with you
anymore I'm choosing a path of peace and
here's what this is going to look like
and you'll sleep and they'll sleep and
that is the soil of new trees
I'm proud of you Jerry it's gonna be
tough because you're gonna have to
unlearn a whole bunch of actions you're
gonna have to learn how to breathe
you're gonna have to learn how to get up
and walk away you're gonna have to learn
how to get in the car and not have had
the last word
and you're also gonna have to learn how
to be a grandma because you're going to
start seeing those kids more and more
the safer your daughter feels around you
you can do this you can do this